[Music]
holy [ __ ] guys Evo 2018 is in the books
and that's a wrap for the world's
biggest fighting game tournament oh
there were moments that gave us
goosebumps and others that made us laugh
that man's pistol he actually got to be
sharing his other testicle with this man
that's a real 50/50 right there in fact
we've got an entire video for you guys
just dedicated to those fails and funny
moments from evolution this year but
this video this video is about the best
of the best
I'm talking about the cream of the crop
from the most incredible Popoff's
[Applause]
to improbable comebacks oh my god oh my
god and of course the filthiest of
combos there is what's it gonna be
junk side and what to the skaters were
punished
here's the best of Evo up to the skies
and he is to be able to be activated
right now okay Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what is going on he is going to grand
finals over food Oh Jim's gonna come to
the next egging with no gloves on can't
use his fist on the baby tantrum Oh
takes the rod we're the perfect whoa
we've punished on the dash attack well
fortunately for canine Yosi not being
able to kill off for grabs but these
eggs though this goes for the spike is
the challenge back
managed to bring this back though choko
is out for blood at this point you see
how he's trying to fish for the back
airs the floods came through it without
loom ago but I really wasn't up special
the tray by the buzzes favorite and
Tocco takes it over to bubble scan this
and it's kept a long response counter
here to sweep this is bad oh you're done
actually doesn't cut this complex this
time barrel throw oh no yeah like that
to protect yourself Sally Sally Bora no
no he traveling with it what that worked
out Betty got that old candy got that
all Wow
the pop oh you are not a playable
character without calories you can't use
your special moves and it's so important
to manage that meter effectively pops
Winnie the round right there that combo
was going to kill sniper rifle just be
home man I would see this good of a shot
since ho Tasha but now he's gonna be
putting the corner oh crush super smart
and the dizzy any went with a jump heavy
putts to make sure it was maximum stun
damage right there that wouldn't
on the ground Oh stayed in the front and
now because oh that wingless yeah
because he charges up the microphone
also that did a little extra damage yep
will you go up against somebody in the
wonky in the hands of somebody like
ozone you're gonna have your money cut
out for you
these fight chasing after them that's it
all gets it down air nice tag coming
from ozone gets Rick
[Music]
we'll all this meter ball Chiquito Nani
these summon Shenron again we're gonna
lose lucky at a full health in my
grandma's marking pull helper spark out
with the flow yes oh he's making
decisions give me the ultimate power
give me though I wanted the hell he
didn't even know what he wanted the lost
soul back to the wall got one game left
to give he's gonna have to win two
straight here against a full wrong
another bad Mercer Nostrum in Monza bow
nod he knows you know will come after
unblockable doesn't escape oh oh he's
scheming I want to see us okay
really place marking or does he take
another character bring the pair at the
back prema
okay we take that we take that he gets
the whole thing yes he is healthy three
wavering up and down just the case oh he
knew that that was not a true block
Street for excellence got the critical
area in between but it's not enough to
kill you loud over the tree will put
Buddha at match point
[Music]
trying to beat any challenge we go in
the corner and still close enough with
the e^x version and now Luffy will the
life lead is gonna go in for more
pressure what a tech oh that's gonna be
bulldog [ __ ] shrug his bow is that
gonna be enough
I believe the raw super and he did not
want that air throw it looked like it
was what he wanted because it was a
conversion but he missed a huge
opportunity
he's won obstacles restarting wizard
opportunities are getting pretty narrow
oh yeah a tech role came into the home
you see me set oh my god
and any sugar should rightfully how cool
challenged
oh what a come out they're just even
spikes it from the costs were looking
for that are ridiculous
well guys you know what they say it's
never over until it's over even when
you're down in rounds down in games and
facing an opponent who clearly has the
download on you with just a pixel of
health magic can happen here are some of
our favorite comebacks from Evo 2018
[Music]
turnaround from title the beast we need
to find that yeah there you go
the thrust into the change if mindset
hit and that's a good damage starter to
go there we go
keep it up 3.5 and oh-oh-oh outer
wonderful coolers no way North they're
not gonna run this back are you
George is running this good close - bail
off eight
oh my god is that Oh donut point unit
fully agency name no version don't say
like his presence that he gets done like
big bird don't say like his presence
we think that he gets stunned by Big
Bird
yup and then what end up with the hi oh
that's a portion of yep coffee over it
back-to-back rounds are we gonna turn
around look at that shimmy Activision
big thing one more for big bird Betty Oh
Eric will come back oh yeah very nice
work big damage round Tweety distinct
have a patient who's ready to is ready
but there we go the tech from big team
if it come into that nib advice with a
beaver back three is good tweeting does
not have the bar there it is surely this
is death oh my god
[Music]
Bojan he is on a tear right now he on
the verge of setting Jamie's New York
and losers oh my god he's goodbye gosh
he's gonna have to be careful though
he's in rage he's gonna beat him he has
to oh you gotta be and that's something
that you rarely get hit by for JDC are
ready time look at the time he's gonna
have to either stay at the time no
sponsors in the air and god I'm it down
marking left you an extra air normals
after those super - level three
you have no choice I mean no - well boys
this is gonna see exactly how is it
gonna go for the mix-up this I guess
I'll grow it dragon brush boys roll -
and on the test tubes I thought you have
go for live pardon me - hey Doc you
glanced early God slicer has three bars
thanks it will be a level three of a
Gahan better it's a holo again since the
doors are the god he is working on a
comeback one more hit here is necessary
but no Tommy what is going to be the
setup Oh
rosie has fireball teleports in Google
in the up back to the swear Oh Coco bike
and you really excels here with his brow
mommy brings that all the way back look
guys Evo is the grandest stage of them
all and competition nerves can hurt
execution but if you do get the chance
to bust out that lab tech on stream why
not right yeah clear them up he's pretty
much done here
Mikey speared at this point you know he
had this time online
oh yeah that's looking pretty wow he's
going to finish that's the fan ready
in the level 3 it's simple yeah there
you go
oh yeah I love this the most delicate
touch on this Yoshi oh that was so sick
you go a kiss right here it could be it
a Sakura purchase my kid okay now he's
gonna notice that
- so for whatever happy for instead
playing a lot of this all fits with ball
me around this background bounces bronze
able to set things up command grab all
the big stuff and he has all this bar he
could just put this name and mix town
it's about to be population mister
violence against another off lockable
the beater he had and just like I talked
about as long as he has the bar he
becomes a blender if you walk into a
Walmart relive the most expensive one
this man is the ninja Oh other side this
should be enough Fujimura get their
diamond again take it from beneath Snake
Eyes yell right
I like I like what the answer is doing
here you know you trying to pick wisely
oh no not like I don't think I'll ever
say it this weekend oh look was like yo
I came to evil expect it to fight
against self better get booze kill this
man oh all of them they have no hand
stick he's like yeah all that curl up
with me well we have a game three or
will we have a - oh another smash the
eye out but oh in the warrant oh that
was never jab reset the devil oh no all
around in that situation maybe
I have a lot of times just spikes them
into the ground that forward air jumping
right behind him crossing both with the
off air setting about for another for
Terry thought you thought he was gonna
wait for the air Todd no sir absolutely
not he's looking very clean this time
around I like that head up coming all
the way to bacon Oh too late bro oh you
don't got those doing on McGee go talk
to Tao hold on he go outside that's how
you feel today we're talking attack you
know him he got seven ball old hold on a
second please hang on a second he
studies anything so yeah he's done hey I
believe I believe that man yup you stole
my brother and me once again
like that rather than try the two aides
didn't get it all artists the breeze
hardest Oh breathe this guy's sonic box
is just making it up as he goes doesn't
fill the level 100 no shampoo there is
what's it gonna be
jump side and escape punished Ryung to
get the follow up afterwards does not
want to commit too hard seeing as it is
a super low good that was just like
catch him falling very very very fat on
tech block these homeless hi snug
connects the high in their mouth already
you might as well get hit by the first
one number three got you now give me
that chain much ball on the lips now
he's in trouble he does have access the
meter
no purse oh and that is adding big
damage yet up this damage oh let's go
what credible choice that is very
desperate okay guys so far we've seen
some sick plays and some filthy combos
but what would those be without the
Popoff's to match
[Applause]
[Applause]
so we tearing through everyone today
taupe
oh that's it's gonna be in Wow very nice
- pop wow you do a little Sun the whole
tournament yeah guys I was just a second
match what is he saying
get security at least he should can
definitely you know what I don't believe
him oh wow disrespect and now he cannot
flush any cannot add tech that's what
happens when you give Tweety oh wow I
wish I could I wish I could have known
what he said - is into it here he goes
oh he's doing he say pick someone else
he's lazy someone out pick someone else
pick a different character because this
won't work you should have put on top
right yeah nice work
Hey all right good games
[Applause]
go back Dragon Ball Z madness Mikey
Mikey and the crowd is loving it
everybody travelers man who's been a
favor for years
Oh director USA in faith the stage here
and I cannot express how much this means
to hook it a wise man once said the only
a real master can come back from this
the patients on the back three big teeth
hello a chewy
[Music]
the public in faith 19 go strange yet
slowly losing his feet are big 16 gonna
be able to get the knock down here
that's it and Theresa qualifies the top
eight oh man I'm so happy the whole day
I think the whole scene is extremely
happy but unfortunately eighty-eight and
super nude makes it the top eight
swarmed by the rest of the Americans get
to see him do it
sadly go raw emotion and this is what I
love to see from all of the players
wants to the ground
you better believe those tears are
coming out Oh bleep oh my god this game
Brad what are you thinking combo
oh okay red hangs on glimpse the legs
and finishes the job nine brought the
books and that birth date though escape
with the jump age boss sold to one over
traces
this is our first the up get booked man
last year we had a lot of brothers in
top 32 no one cracked up they all take
be this huge you got your American New
York SAS the TSB next level
oh the man is a popper that he was
scared you were scared when that radar
was activated not interested any of the
Ganges whatsoever man no ha is not in
the swarm tokino husband sent home in
second place coming from the losers in
order to beat sonic box sonic box I will
need to win one day we go oh that was so
loud talk to me that was music to my ear
Lowe's evolution 2018 champion he's dead
he's done it all those years sonic Fox
back to back Evo champion multi time Evo
champion and our rest games he's done at
all everybody said he only wins in the
games people don't play everybody starts
this way akashi-kun has made a place is
kind of keep himself warm trying to
build up that energy wake himself up
guys Evo is a meat grinder world-class
players drown in pools relative unknowns
make it to greatness in top 8 and upsets
do happen here are some of our favorites
from this year's evolution Oh dick for
expand she wants the percent he's some
of these options he went although ok
wait Oh fishy
wait he's got control the down air Oh
into King what - get off me down smash
is that how he's gonna get key oh he got
the sweet spot the connection what up
what a draw of the cards here but early
on in the morning
I love it I love the iron our board can
Swedish get it done or can Armada stave
off another challenger
okay gets the tech chase crab goes for
the up smash hoping to catch them on is
fall ok ok this is big this is really
big you know hard by how violent how can
you tech taste in this situation
and you got the border great tech from
our mana oh that drill was this is
always oh wait a second so I okay goes
low getting the slide me any business -
[Applause]
the mirrors Oh got another throw we so
give me three give me three that's the
pushes buttons up their baggage on the
py unseen couldn't get the prick up with
the 2h though get thanks and punish
others ending oh my god corner push not
getting low on resources now gets their
hand after the bridle it was so well
spaceball choice guys he's in position
looking for the dead end over the desert
column has to block the ball the upset
eliminates no gain and again his place
okay JDC are or he gets it one more he
could do it oh my gosh
[Applause]
Paris I can't believe what I'm seeing
guys can I get a break any chance I know
we wanted to take a break but there's
any chance we could get a gurney I'm
gonna need some help I need more water
two guys playing him level three yeah
and this damage is gonna stick because
the sparking is no longer active gonna
get a hard knockdown I'm gonna say super
jump
super jump super - yeah baby no okay God
in pool another year another Evo guys
and man this one was sick I mean problem
X with the Bison left and finally
winning melee and of course the Evo
debut of Dragon Ball fighters what makes
me want to watch it all over again and
if you agree hit that replay button and
let's go thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button